ici aussi
déplacer donc là quand parfois on veut
descendre dans le bunker et les choses
quand il y a pas de trucs d'électricité
donc c'est comme ça
donc ça c'est Mariame
y
mais ça reste toujours ses
collègues
c'est ici qu'on mettait les matelas donc
ça là vers levé on dégage tout ça on
dégage tout ça ça tirait quand même on
entendait beaucoup de coups de feu et ça
parfois ça faisait vibrer les fenêtres
et je demandais aux enfants elle me
disent que non ils ne veulent pas partir
et ma femme aussi elle veut pas partir
donc on est resté
voir
le petit
jusqu'à ce que vraiment j'ai entendu le
bruit là je ne pouvais pas imaginer
puisque pour moi c'était des
frères et jusqu'à présent je pense que
c'est une santé quand on n'a pas assez
d'arguments c'est les coups de poing
c'est les coups de physique c'est ce qui
peut régler mais quand on est
intelligent quand on est intellectuel
pour moi il y a toujours d'autres
arguments qu'on peut utiliser sans
passer par vraiment c'est tuerie
et c'est comme ça
me donnait même beaucoup de courage de
ne pas rester à la maison c'est de venir
quand tu vois que tu as aidé il est
monté dans le train et déjà c'est un ouf
de soulagement
je vois honnêtement des personnes quand
même qui sont âgées et j'imagine combien
de fois les gens ont souffert pour se
faire un appartement et les gens sont là
maintenant sans absolument rien je
trouve que c'est une main
dans ma tête j'avais perdu le business
donc on parlait même plus de business je
suis simplement j'essayais de maintenir
un lien avec les employés il aurait été
pour moi mais hors de question de dire à
mes équipes écouter je suis en France
vous continuez à travailler je suis
joignable mais moi je reste en France
c'est juste non c'est un choix délibéré
assumer et
revendiquer certaines personnes m'ont
dit effectivement mais par tu as pas
besoin d'être là si je crois honnêtement
j'ai besoin de toi
j'ai besoin parce que il y a on peut
faire beaucoup de choses
on n'a pas forcément besoin d'être sur
le front pour être actif dans la dans la
guerre contre la Russie
et puis c'est ça c'est une photo qui
date du mois de
juin je pense
c'est un prix en France et en fait j'ai
fait plusieurs allers-retours avec une
camionnette de la société pour aller
chercher des des garrots ça tout ça sont
des garrots militaires un garrotoniké
différents matériels de secours il y
avait des extincteurs
[Musique]
de voir si le jour la victoire sera
sur un proclamée
[Musique]